[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
you
[Music]
so
hi everyone my name is don jacobs
and i just want to welcome you all to
the table tonight we're so thrilled that
you are all here
it has been kind of a crazy season for
me personally
um i've been parking all my heavens a
lot
a lot it has been one of those things
where i've even had to work
last sunday it was really kind of hard
to kind of miss
uh some of the things that were going on
in the church
last week um and because of that i had
to kind of catch up
and the way i did that was um
i went to i don't know if how many
people are aware of this but i had to
kind of catch up
by going to the podcast that table has
uh to kind of catch up on the
conversation that happened um
last week and i'm so thankful that
we have a system that's set up that if
you do miss a sunday if you do
miss a very important conversation that
you can't
that you don't want to miss that they
are archived
you can go back and listen to previous
sermons or or conversations that went on
that she
may have possibly missed for some reason
or another
um so i had the opportunity doing that
this last sunday
and so if that's something that you guys
are not familiar with or anything like
that
um so i know sarah's going to post
something in the comments below about
with the link to the uh podcast that was
specifically in apple but they're
available like on spotify and other
different kinds of
podcasts and systems as well so go make
sure you check that out
if you haven't had the opportunity to do
so
i also just want to do another a quick
announcement
um so we know that there's the
possibility of just
reopening with live services
for the new year and that's something
that the eldership team
has been giving into prayer is giving a
special attention to
and so brett's going to be sending out
an email communication on that topic
um coming up that that you want to make
sure
that you don't want to miss out on so um
so if you so so the only kind of email
that you are getting from the table
is the weekly email that brent is
sending out
that you want to check with us to ensure
that you're on the church's
email list so if that's something you're
not sure about just send us a message
either like an email address with your
contact information either through the
website or just kick us a message
private message in the
um the facebook table facebook that
would be awesome
i just want to close this uh or this
part
of us with just a quick prayer before we
get
started with worship lord thank you so
much for this opportunity
um to get together in this way thank you
so much for each person
who is tuning in this evening tonight
and even people who might be listening
uh later on i
pray that you will just open up their
hearts
their minds to who you are to what you
are doing in their lives
i pray that they um just can just
connect with you in a deep and powerful
way
and all these things in christ i pray
amen
hey everybody welcome to the table thank
you so much for joining us online
tonight
uh again really miss seeing you guys in
person
i hope you had a really good week um if
you had a bad week
that's okay if you had a mediocre week
that's okay too
everybody's welcome here uh but right
now
i just ask that you sit back take some
deep breaths
watch the week away look forward to the
week that's coming
and just dive into the words of this
song sing it if you know it
but just sit back and relax try and take
the load off
[Music]
many men will drink the rain
turn to thank the clouds
[Music]
many men will hear you
speak they will never
turn around
[Music]
but i will not forget you
but
[Music]
in my sacrifices
not what
[Music]
thankful prayer i
huge bell i raised
[Music]
is
many men will pour their gold
[Music]
serve a thing that shines
many men will read your words
they will never change their minds
[Music]
but i will not forget you
you are my god my king
with a thankful heart
and my sacrifices
not what you can give
but what i alone can
give
[Music]
dance
[Applause]
[Music]
loud song i say
a life
[Music]
i will not forget you
but my god
[Music]
sacrifices not what you
can care but what i
alone can give to
[Music]
you
okay
hey table family thanks josh brock so
much for sharing that song with us
um when brett told me what he was going
to be talking about tonight he was
uh saying that kind of the natural bent
[Music]
and as i processed that i was thinking
like what's the natural antidote
for negativity
[Music]
thoughts that can destroy um thoughts
that take us to dark places and
acknowledges the good
um and for me
it's so important to acknowledge where
that good comes from
and
[Music]
creative god forgiving god
restoring god so
tonight as we worship i hope that you
are able to engage the space from a
place of gratitude
and if you don't feel like you're in
that space right now um i
understand i've been there i i go there
often um but i just hope that you can
give yourself permission
to shift the narrative tonight to open
yourself up to a different storyline
and maybe just um posture your heart in
a way
that allows god to shed light on some of
the goodness around you
um because sometimes it's hard for us to
see it on our own
um so thank you guys for
kind of going through this gratitude
experiment with us throughout the night
and uh just join us as you're able to
[Music]
bless the lord of my soul
lord my soul
worship his holy name
sing like never before
oh my soul
i worship your holy name
the sun comes up again
[Music]
me
oh
[Music]
your name is great and your heart is
worship is
[Applause]
oh my soul
[Music]
and on that day when my strength
has
years forever
[Music]
oh soul
[Applause]
[Music]
is
you're
[Music]
you're never gonna let me
you're never gonna let me down
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
you're never gonna let me
you're never never
oh you are
[Music]
jesus thank you so much
for who you are for what you do in our
[Music]
lives
mindy was gonna read a scripture right i
was gonna read a scripture right she was
[Music]
let her grab her bible for a moment all
right
let's try that again guys
this is a passage from james one this is
the message bible that i'm reading out
of
it says so my very dear friends don't
get thrown off course
every desirable good and perfect
gift comes out of heaven the gifts
are rivers of light cascading down
from the father of light there is
nothing deceitful in god
nothing two-faced nothing fickle
he brought us to life using the true
word
and showing us off as the crown of all
his creatures
i love that there is nothing deceitful
in god
nothing two-faced nothing fickle
[Music]
god would you keep bringing us to life
would you continue your work inside of
us transforming us god
we need your goodness
we need your grace
right now especially in our world we are
surrounded
and even sometimes ourselves bringing in
darkness pain pride
competition ugliness
but god we want to be people of light we
want to be people of kindness
and compassion and truth and justice
[Music]
we want to be the ones bringing the
character and nature of god
into the world around us god
so would you help us to shift our
posture from negativity
into hope from darkness into light
would you make us aware of the gifts
that you've given us
would you surround us with your beauty
and when the rest of the world refuses
to look at it
god would we be the ones shining a light
on
would we be the ones seeking it out and
pursuing it
and bringing it to life around us
[Music]
we love you keep rooting us
into who you are send your name i pray
all these things
amen
[Music]
thank you guys for sharing the space
with us
well good evening my friends grace and
peace
it's so good to be with all of you and
uh
i hope uh you know that you know whether
tonight you
are just full of faith in god or
full of doubt uh regardless of your
gender or your race or sexual
orientation or class level or
intelligence or moral uprightness or
physical appearance regardless like
all of that uh you are welcome at the
table
and i pray this can be a community where
you feel that sense of love and
acceptance
uh you know not that we're a perfect
community we we certainly are not
but we are doing our best to live into
that that expansive inclusive love of
god that we've come to know in christ
so uh thank you for being with us and
tonight
uh if you are joining us maybe for the
first time this is a good night to join
because we're kicking off a brand new
series
uh it's titled stretched what to do
when life pushes you to the limit and
for many of us the last nine months have
been
a butt kicking i mean yes it's true god
is good
and faithful but life can be really hard
and when you add this uh virus and more
recently even just the days
the weeks kind of surrounding the
election that was fun
on top of you know just life itself
which frankly
it already has enough stress
enough relational breakdown financial
pressure
job pressure uh self-loathing
substance abuse addiction
children learning not to act like
barbarians like it can all just be
you know a bit much and so in this
series
we'll be looking at uh both the
teachings of and stories from the life
of jesus to see um just what what they
might have to say to
to a people like us so with that in mind
the title of my message tonight is
teflon velcro and the mind
so i want to kind of frame up our
discussion in this way have you ever
had a moment where you should have been
just incredibly stressed out like where
where
where your brain should have been going
bananas on you like it should have been
screaming
warning warning this this is not good
life
life is not going well and yet
for some bizarre reason you were just
perfectly at peace perhaps it was
the superfood chia seeds you consumed
the previous night
or the fact you just read you know an
inspiring book that just had you in a
good headspace
or you may have been faithful to your
prayer routine
you know whatever the reason but life
punched you in the mouth and you
just stood there seemingly unaffected
grinning like a happy fool has
says that ever happened to you uh i hope
so because honestly
it is a revelation uh
honestly i wish i had this experience
more often
but one time in particular that comes to
mind is the night i ended up sleeping
in a car in portland oregon
so to make a long story short it was
just it was one of those nights where
everything went wrong uh i had to fly to
portland because of seminaries this was
a few years ago
um and my flight i almost always had a
layover in denver
and so i get to denver and you know just
one of those nights where
uh weather delays was just repeatedly
you know delay after delay after delay
and my
layover uh which meant then i i kind of
landed
in portland uh at midnight
so you know off to a good start and then
i get to my airbnb
um but i remember we just kept circling
the block
um because like there were a few houses
that we thought it could be
um but they they just didn't have clear
like numbers you know marking the homes
and of course i mean i'm there like it's
so
late um that i'm hesitant to knock on a
potential wrong door like damn here
you know i mean by now um i mean i'm
calling my hostess over and over and
over
and it's i mean it must be 1 30 a.m and
you know she's not answering
and of course 1 30 in portland uh
is 3 30 a.m my time so
you know it's not a great night so
finally we just we give up
and i go with my friends to their hotel
uh
but but my friend he basically had like
his whole family with him even like his
mother
and then his wife and kid and so they
were you know pretty packed into this
room
i was on a budget and there was no way
i mean at this point what it's like
we're getting to the hotel it's 2
30 2 2 30 something and i'm gonna have
to be uh at school
the next day like you know eight seven
thirty eight so i'm like there's just no
way i'm gonna pay 80
to sleep in a fancy room for five hours
that's ridiculous is that your breath
thing all my friends right now are
rolling their eyes
just pay the money brett no
no and so i asked my friend jesse watts
some of you know jesse and kasia
they'll probably listen this message at
some point um
i said hey um because they said they
were like
kind of inviting me oh just stay with us
in our room but i was like no
no no no and so i just said you know
what hey do you mind if i just sleep in
the back of your rental car
and the look on their faces to this day
i don't totally know what they were
thinking
but their eyes said this is a very
strange human being
and so they i mean they're begging me
like just stay in the room i just went
no no it's my choice like i have you
know the money but i just
i just don't want to do that um i just
don't want to pay you know
and so they graciously they give me the
keys and i walk out to the rental car
and there i stand in the parking lot of
this obscure hotel or really motel and
i'm i'm
it's like now it's 2 30 a.m or so um
i'm putting on a second pair of pants
because it's chilly out this was winter
i think it was february there um and so
i mean it was real chilly and so
i you know i'm layering up i'm putting
on my layers
at 2 33 am i crawl into the back seat
and i did the whole roll up the t-shirts
thing you know for a pillow
and so i rolled him up and i
lay down and of course you know i can't
stretch out my legs so i kind of did
that you know
kind of trying to turn and make myself
pretzel some you know
and so there i lay and i mean honestly i
should have been upset
right i should have been exhausted and
stressed and normally
let's just be clear i would have been
but for whatever reason
that night i was perfectly at ease
i remember thinking to myself like i'm
laying there
and i'm like why do i feel such peace
i i should be freaking out right now
uh and i was kind of freaked out that i
wasn't freaking out
but i wasn't i was not freaking out i
was fine
and of course i mean there are people in
the world who sleep like that every
night their lives
and they're not freaking out so it was
okay i was okay
and i recall wondering the next day like
what what was that
was that like was that a mystical
experience of god or something because i
can't understand
why i go through so many of my days
so unhappy so discon so discontent
so unsatisfied and yet there i was in
the back of a rental car cramped and
cold
feeling perfectly well in body in mind
and if you ever um
flip through my journal entries in the
last five years since then
you'll see a recurring phrase and the
phrases brett i say this to myself
brett remember that night in portland
that's the line remember that night in
portland and i always know exactly which
one i'm talking about
uh and of course what do i mean i i'm
saying to myself brett remember the
night
where everything went terribly wrong
but you were happy because i tell you
that's a revelation i really do believe
looking back on it i do believe it was a
god moment of sorts
i think it was kind of god through my
circumstances tapping me on the shoulder
and asking brett do you get it
do you see what why don't you
trust me uh let me put it like this
to worry is human to find
peace divine to worry is human
to find peace divine in other words to
be discontent
is human to be stressed is human to be
afraid is human to be jealous
and angry and frustrated is human to be
ungrateful
and hacked off and upset
is human to be happy
divine to be at peace divine to find joy
welling up from within you
regardless of the imperfections of the
world divine
because of course the story we tell
ourselves
is well the reason i'm unhappy the
reason i'm
not at peace the reason i'm not fine is
because
the world out there it is not allowing
me to be that way
uh but it just isn't so i mean sure
like it can really help when stars align
and circumstances conspire
to make uh your and my life easier
but the fact that our world can be
melting down
and for at least a brief moment we can
be at peace
that should be a sign it is a sign it's
assigned to us
to all of us that that it's not about
the stars the lining it's not about the
circumstances
what's it about it's about us it's it's
my
own heart my own mind
in matthew chapter 6 verses 25 through
34. if you
some of you will remember right the very
beginning of the pandemic
uh i preached on this passage at least a
portion of it and i think it's time to
revisit it
so jesus speaks just directly to this
and um normally when we read scripture
we put the passage up on the screen
right now but
this time as i read i want you to
contemplate this is a painting it's
titled
christ in the wilderness consider
the lilies i love this painting i'm so
intrigued by it
uh it's yeah i just think it's really
kind of
um i don't know something beautiful and
different
about it so this is um christ
considering the lilies which of course
in this passage you'll hear that
referenced
so jesus says
therefore i tell you do not worry about
your life
what you will eat or drink or about your
body
what you will wear is not life more than
food in the body more than clothes
and look at the birds of the air they do
not sow or
reap or store away in barns and yet your
heavenly father
feeds them are you not much more
valuable than they
can any one of you by worrying at a
single hour to your life
and why do you worry about clothes see
how the flowers of the field grow they
do not labor
or spin yet i tell you that not even
king solomon and all his
splendor was dressed like one of these
if that is how god
clothes the grass of the field which is
here today and tomorrow is thrown into
the fire
will he not much more clothe you oh you
have little faith
do not worry saying what shall we eat or
what shall we drink or what shall we
wear
for the pagans in other words the people
who don't believe in god they run after
all these things
and yet your heavenly father knows
that you need them but seek first
his kingdom and his righteousness
and all these things will be given to
you as well therefore do not worry about
tomorrow
for tomorrow will worry about itself
each day has enough trouble of its own
so here's jesus saying
do not worry in other words
do not fret or freak out or live in fear
about what
is happening or what may happen
do not do that in fact the statement do
not worry
repeats itself three times in the
passage
and the word worry itself shows up a
total of six times
so i think the message is clear that
that thing
that that you were doing don't
stop it don't don't do that but of
course what's the truth
oh like what do we do all day every day
non-stop
well we fret and obsess and mentally
argue and generally give ourselves over
to
worry and anxiety in perpetuity at least
if you're anything like me and uh i i'm
not saying that to shame us i'm just
naming
like that's that's the reality right
that's where we begin
now the question i think is really
really interesting
uh is is have you ever thought about why
that is i want to give you one
scientific take on this i promise it
won't take too long
um but basically it seems that our
nervous systems
have have evolved to above all else um
not pursue the good or
revel in the glory and beauty of the
world
no our nervous system evolved to do what
to
avoid the bad
why well because um our goal
was survival right it is survival that's
what your brain has evolved to do first
and foremost keep you alive and our
great great great great grandparents
they were the survivors and they were
the cautious
ones the fearful ones the ones who when
the bushes shook
20 yards from them they didn't yawn
and think to themselves ah it's probably
nothing
our ancestors the the ones who lived to
pass on their jeans
they were the ones who when those bushes
shook they
jumped and they ran and they did not
look back right they were on high alert
all day every day because what mattered
above all else was survival
the happy-go-lucky ones got eaten
we are the descendants and this is a
strange thing to think about but it's
true right
we are the descendants of total nervous
wrecks
uh and of course in a bizarre twist of
history we no longer live on the
savannah we no longer live in fear of
the saber-toothed tigers
and so you'd think
we would just be blissfully happy all
day every day
i mean it is a little ironic that every
morning
i pray you know god give us this day our
daily bread it's for the lord's prayer
give us this day our daily bread
uh and every time i pray that in the
mornings i can't help but i immediately
think of my pantry
which is packed full of food
and if i'm completely honest um in my 18
adult years
it has never run out not one time
ah and yet i still pray it right like i
guess i want to be a good christian so
give us a dare daily bread and i know
there's other ways to you know
think of that but um i mean so you'd
think
like well i've got it made i mean
because presumably the people that jesus
taught to pray that prayer that was like
a legit prayer you know but so you think
i'd be doing just cartwheels of joy all
day uh i mean like even the things jesus
is talking about in the passage we just
read for example um
you know clothes you know
water right don't worry about what
you'll drink
like you know running out of clothes
fresh water is this my
the thing i wake up like oh gosh i'm
just nervous like
no that that's not even a worry for me
so again i mean i'm imagining ancient
peoples would look at me
just like you live like a king
i should i should be jumping for joy
but nope
uh why why because
our minds my mind it is a worry
machine i'm trying
just to survive in a world where
statistically speaking it's not
actually that hard to live to a ripe old
age anymore
but it's almost like we're all kind of
grizzled war veterans who have
physically left the battlefield
and returned home and yet we continue to
fight the war in our minds
uh dr rick hansen he's a a psychologist
and
i think a neuroscientist and he's
someone who's done quite a bit of
writing on this
topic um he explains it this way so this
is what our brains are doing
all day every day so he kind of has five
points here
um so first we scan the environment
for threats in bad news
if you are an enneagram six you do this
like 10 times as much as the normal
population but everyone else still we're
humans
and so we're like scanning the
environment for threats and bad news
um this by the way is why you know
people will say things like well you
know what
all these news stations like the actual
media news they just they're just always
putting out bad news
i'm gonna be different i'm gonna start a
news station where we just put out good
news
just good news all day yeah that's
idealistic of you because frankly it
would fail
like people have tried this and no one
watches
[Laughter]
because why because what do we find just
magnetic bad
negativity right because we're our
brains this is how they work we're just
scanning for threats
bad news like dangers all right so
that's first we scan the environment for
threats and bad news
second we then over focus hansen says we
over focus
on the bad news uh and then of course we
overreact to the bad news and this isn't
just a value like a judgment thing he's
saying like
literally we have this tendency to to
just
have an a hyper response to it that is
like
um excessive this is what we do so we
over we over focus on the bad news we
then overreact
to the bad news number four we then
fast track the bad news deep
into our memory i mean anything right
any um experience that has a lot of
emotion behind
it our brains say ah that's important
that's right so
when we feel deep fear over something
our brains say ah
important very important they and so
what happens it fast tracks it deep into
our memory
and then number five we then sensitize
our brain to the negative because if
you're going through these four steps
over and over and over you're literally
you're telling your brain
this is this is what's important in the
world and you become
hypersensitive to the negative this is
why our brains have men as mindy said
earlier what psychology psychologists
call a
negativity bias right and you say oh
i'm different no you're not this is like
this is just
human beings with the way our brains we
are hardwired
to register and dwell on negative
thoughts experiences
and feelings and we just and of course
people might be
um have this kind of in a more deep
intense way and some less
but we are all we're all biased
um towards the negative
so um this is why for example when you
have an annual review with your boss
this is so classic
and um you know they someone gives you a
meaning if you haven't been in a boss
setting but
it doesn't matter right like just a
situation where someone gave you like
say four areas of like positive feedback
and then negative feedback in one area
or heck i mean it could be like
you know eight eight positive
things too negative i mean just you know
give me wildly
um uh just kind of weighted slanted
towards the positive
and then you go out that night with your
friends and they ask you hey by the way
how did that review go what you don't
say
is oh my gosh it went
awesome they said i did good in like
four out of five areas four out of five
i'm killing it that's like 80 greatness
i'm probably even above
average no no what do you and i obsess
over for the next week
the negative the one failure
the one struggle the one bad thing it
just gets driven into our hearts
into our minds we're just obsessing i
mean or think of it this way
um some of you are in meetups and things
like kind of our small groups
um which are great i encourage you all
to do this um
and there it's powerful because these
are kind of support groups
but think of it like this when was the
last time you heard someone in a small
group
respond to the question how are you
doing this week
with a statement something like this
guys
i am like so obsessed with the good
things happening in my life right now i
mean i'm just so happy
i i can't even focus on my problems
long enough to get them fixed
i'm like come on self you got to pay at
least a little attention to the
challenges in your life i mean
guys it's becoming a real issue uh
yeah said no one in a small group ever
and but i love how dr hansen he puts it
he kind of sums this up he says the mind
it is like velcro highly sticky
for negative experiences and teflon
for positive ones not beautiful the mind
is
velcro for negative experiences and
teflon just slides right off for
positive
ones what's the takeaway here um
we're negative people because that's the
default mode of our mind in other words
when we hear
that teaching of jesus from matthew 6
um we shouldn't i don't think it should
fill us with shame
right or when he's asking like why why
do you worry why do you
i don't think it should be like an
accusation but he's saying hey
pay attention can you see how
just negative flat out negative we are i
heard the story
of a man he went on a very long solitary
meditation retreat it was just him
lots of quiet uh lots of prayer
meditation
for literally not like days or weeks but
months and months and months
and afterwards he was debriefing with a
group of people
and of course they're very excited to
hear like okay what
what nugget what what wisdom he had
gleaned
from such a unique remarkable experience
and he said you know honestly it took me
until the very
end of the retreat to finally accept the
fact
he said that i could not trust
my brain what it told
me about myself what it told me about
others what it told me about the world
now why what does he mean well it's
everything we've been talking about
it's velcro and it's teflon it's the
negativity bias
it's the way we over focus on the bad
overreact to the negative
worrying about things that we are
powerless to change
obsessing over things that may never
even happen
and not just that but in the process
right because the teflon side
ignoring the good
ignoring the good jesus says it consider
the lilies of the field in other words
pay attention
to this beautiful thing that's precisely
what we don't do
right we ignore the good we pay almost
zero attention to the beautiful and we
constantly turn
away from the positive
all right so what's the good news like
what can we do here's what i want to
kind of name
bring we've got to learn to bring our
attention
bring your attention to the here and
then now
i think this is essentially what jesus
is saying in verse 34 when he he names
therefore
do not worry about tomorrow
right for tomorrow we'll worry about
itself almost inevitably if we are
thinking about either
yesterday or tomorrow
and we're obsessing one of those two
directions either past or future
almost inevitably it's bad i mean like
on occasion
we'll have a vacation coming up and
we're thinking about tomorrow in a
positive sense i can't wait to get there
uh but that's rare right 95 or maybe
99.9
of the time it's almost always regrets
about the past
oh how could that happen how could they
say that to me i can't believe that
happened
or anxieties about the future oh gosh
what if
what oh no so what's the solution keep
returning to what jesus calls today
there's a word that i found really
helpful recently
in this regard it's the word awareness
awareness simply being aware
aware of the external world aware
of your inside world just watching
watching the crazy thoughts maybe
smiling at them a bit
but certainly above all else not
believing them
and and definitely not acting on them
just being aware awareness by the way a
great book on this topic is by the
jesuit priest anthony demelo i've linked
to it in my e-letter
so i'm sure all of you already bought it
it's titled awareness brilliant
brilliant book
very thought provoking so when i think
back to that night in portland
i think this is some of what i was
experiencing
it's like i was aware of what was
happening like oh
well this isn't good but for whatever
reason that night i
wasn't caught up in the drama
too often we are just getting caught up
in our own
self-created stories and dramas don't we
we write fantastic dramas we're as good
as the tv writers
like the dramas written in our minds oh
my goodness
uh friends you and i we we must refuse
to get caught up in in our minds
self-created drama we gotta start
letting that crap go
because inevitably what happens this
pulls us
either to yesterday or tomorrow
but never to the moment
and um and honestly if you think about
the present moment like the actual
present moment
rarely has drama like very rarely
so inevitably i mean if you think of
something even you're very anxious about
it's like
the actual experience of the thing often
might
you know last just a few minutes and yet
we will spend
weeks months um you know or you think of
a yeah difficult experience from the
past that we might spend
years ruminating on right when the
actual experience
was five minutes interesting but this is
what we do
right so um so if you're feeling very
emotional and dramatic uh
it's probably a moment to kind of
question yourself like hmm
am i am i in the moment am i being aware
and or am i getting pulled into
yesterday or
tomorrow and so what we've got to do in
that moment is kind of
step back in awareness and watch it
that's what it means to be here
to be in the present moment to be aware
now you might ask well what on earth
does this have to do with god uh that's
a good question here's what i think
you'll find a
living in awareness grows your faith
in god isn't this what jesus said in
verse 30 oh
you of little faith that was his line oh
you have a little faith in other words
you're running around here
and there caught up in your own little
dramas
not at peace not at rest in fact you
might say
that that the proportion of internal
drama
in your life is correlated to your faith
in god
more drama less faith less trust
less drama and that's probably a sign of
more faith more trust
um so that's a uh living in awareness it
grows your faith in god
b living in awareness grows your sense
of connectedness
to god see if you want to begin to live
in the presence of god
if you want to live a life of love you
and i
must become massively
aware massively present
because when we do that we become
much more calm contented
uh grateful patient
tuned in to ourselves to others
in the world and if we are to trust the
great saints in christian history
those kind of attributes those kind of
virtues that's precisely
what it takes to live with a constant
sense of connectedness to god
you see to worry is human
to find peace divine
i'm gonna close uh with this story this
um
the author for this is is unknown
there's a few it's kind of attributed to
a few different people
um so i don't know who wrote it but it's
titled two wolves
an old man was teaching his grandson
about life
and so he explained a fight is going on
inside me it is a terrible fight
and it is between two wolves
one is evil he is anger
envy hatred ego he continued the other
is love he is joy peace goodness
generosity faith
the same fight he explained is going on
inside you
and inside every other person too
the grandson thought about it for a
minute and then ask this question
which wolf will win the old man replied
the one that you feed
you pray with me lord jesus
i ask for the grace for every person
hearing my voice
for the grace to consider the lilies of
the field
to see to experience to enjoy the beauty
and the goodness
around us to see
how nature is never in a rush your
creation is never in a rush
and yet everything happens
got to realize that all of these things
that we think we need
um we really don't and that it's enough
to
to have you so god help us to trust
help us to have faith in in god um
for every worry every concern every
burden that we carry
um god we give those over to you
if you're praying with me now and you
have a burden
that you've been carrying i invite you
to just open up your hands
just that kind of as a sign of just
giving it to god
maybe there's a uh one of your
children's been struggling
you have financial pressures job stress
maybe just social anxiety and a sense of
fear of
rejection from others
all the things that just feel out of our
control right now
god we give them over to you and we ask
that
faith would arise that love would arise
god that presence and awareness would
arise
god transform us from the inside out
it's in the powerful and life-changing
name of jesus that i pray
amen
thanks brett that was um just great food
for thought for us to be considering
i love what adam posted uh just to ask
ourselves that question
from that story you just read which wolf
are we feeding
and right now i wanted us to take some
time i know in this
online format that we have for our
services it can be
difficult to not have that same
interaction that we feel when we're in
the same room
at the same time together but i wanted
us to try something
just in the spirit of turning
our attention our awareness towards
gratitude towards gratefulness
towards the good the pure the beautiful
the right the true i wondered if you
guys
would do this little interactive um
exercise with us as we close out our
service tonight
and um let's take the time
if you're watching live would you
comment
something that you're grateful for in
your life something that is true and
beautiful
something that's a gift from god to you
um
would you mind putting that in the
comments and i'm just gonna have maggie
play
for a little bit without any lyrics
without any words
just for us to reflect and remember the
good
and turn our thoughts posture our heart
towards gratitude
especially as we go into this week of
thanksgiving um i just thought this
would be a beautiful
exercise for us to do together as a
community so if you're bold enough if
you're brave enough
join us in posting that and we'll share
them in this time together
um and i'll go ahead and read them out
loud for those who may not be
i know some are on youtube some are on
facebook
and some watch our services later and
aren't able to see the comments so i'll
go ahead and read them out
um as you're posting and then we'll
finish out with the chorus together
all right thanks guys
[Music]
i love this um lily may
who is five years old says she's
grateful for her people
i love that lily me too
[Music]
stephanie says i'm grateful for sisters
and brothers in faith
chris brown says i'm grateful for those
that pray for me
haley says becoming a mom to my daughter
indy indy is beautiful
i love seeing her
adam says i'm grateful for all of you in
my life
that god led me to the table and to you
all
[Music]
yeah grateful to be a part of your life
adam
sarah says i'm grateful for books
[Music]
joseph says i'm grateful for the
blessing of my daughter
don says i'm thankful for time with my
kids
brett says i'm grateful for my boys and
my little girl
[Music]
nelda says i'm grateful to god for his
walk beside me
and for my family and my friends
[Music]
i want to share i'm grateful for
relationships that have been restored
this year
[Music]
um
and i will not forget you
you are my god my king
with a thankful heart i
bring my offerings
and my sacrifices
and not what you can give
but what i alone can
give to you
a grateful heart i give
a thankful pair i pray
a wild dance i dance me
for you a loud song i see
a huge bellaring
a life
[Music]
i live before you
thank you guys so much for joining us in
that i hope you all have a great
thanksgiving week
oh thank you uh both maggie mindy that
was a
wonderful beautiful and thank you
everyone that was able to participate
with us tonight
um thank you for joining us uh if you
are in need of prayer or support
at this time you please send us a
message in facebook and we'll have one
of our leaders follow up with you
and then also if this resonated with um
with you with the values of the table we
want to invite invite you to
to ensure this community can continue
doing the work
um that it does so if you wouldn't mind
doing that you can go to
the website and give the the table
tx.org and then as we close tonight
i do want to send us out with this
benediction
um it is from ephesians 6.
peace be to the brothers and with the
love of faith
for god the father and the lord jesus
christ
grace be with all who love the lord
jesus christ with love uncorrectable
thank you and have a blessed week
you